bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de Descartes
j'aime à dire que des cartes est un
philosophe contre qui la postérité c'est
ligué
quand on cite Descartes après le 17e
siècle c'est rarement pour lui rendre
hommage
c'est plutôt pour le contredire
voir pour dire qu'il s'était trompé
surtout
il se serait trompé sur Dieu en échouant
à prouver son existence
il se serait trompé sur la connaissance
en excluant de la connaissance la
perception
il se serait trompé sur les passions sur
l'âme
et aussi c'est ce qui va nous intéresser
aujourd'hui
sur la liberté
alors en réalité on va le voir par la
suite tous ces sujets sont étroitement
liés
la conception cartésienne de l'âme
découle de sa conception de Dieu
de même que sa conception de la liberté
découle de sa conception de l'âme
le fait est que quand on est en
désaccord sur plusieurs points avec un
philosophe
il y a fort à parier que ce soit avec
ses postulats qu'on est en désaccord
avec sa vision du monde en tant que tel
donc aujourd'hui on va s'intéresser à ce
que disait Descartes à propos de la
liberté et pour poser quelques bases on
va commencer par expliquer en quoi la
vision cartésienne de la liberté
s'oppose à celle d'un autre philosophe
bien connu un philosophe qu'on apprécie
beaucoup sur cette chaîne à savoir
Spinoza
on sait que pour Spinoza la liberté
c'est une illusion
la liberté au sens de pouvoir
d'autodétermination
pour Spinoza ça n'existe pas
spinozan nous dit l'homme se croit libre
parce qu'il ignore les causes qui le
déterminent
traduction
des cartes se trompent
il se trompe quand il affirme que
l'homme est libre
plus exactement quand il affirme que
l'homme possède un libre arbitre
la différence entre la liberté et le
libre arbitre c'est que le libre arbitre
c'est une liberté intérieure
le libre arbitre c'est la liberté de ma
conscience
si je vis dans une société où on
m'empêche de faire ce que je veux par
exemple où on m'empêche d'exprimer mes
opinions
je ne suis pas libre
physiquement parlant
pour autant ce n'est pas incompatible
avec le fait de posséder un libre
arbitre
inversement si ma conscience est sous
influence
soit parce que quelqu'un exerce une
emprise mentale sur moi
soit parce que j'ai consommé de l'alcool
ou d'autres substances
à ce moment-là je peux être parfaitement
libre de mes mouvements mais ma
conscience elle n'est pas libre
donc quand on parle de liberté en
philosophie on parle en réalité
principalement du libre arbitre c'est à
dire de la liberté au niveau de la
conscience
donc je disais Descartes croyez dans
l'existence du libre arbitre
et non seulement il y croyait mais il y
voyait même la caractéristique
essentielle de l'homme
pour Descartes ce qui sépare l'homme de
l'animal c'est justement le libre
arbitre
c'est cette aptitude proprement humaine
à pouvoir s'autodéterminer dans ses
pensées et dans ses agissements
et qu'est-ce qui fait que Descartes
croyaient dans le libre arbitre humain
et bien c'est ce qu'on va tenter de
comprendre aujourd'hui
la première raison pour laquelle
Descartes croyait dans le libre arbitre
humain
c'était pas une raison philosophique
qu'une raison religieuse
alors sur cette chaîne on ne discute pas
des options religieuses de chacun
en revanche on s'interroge sur la
signification philosophique de certaines
options religieuses
Oris se trouve que dans le catholicisme
puisque Descartes étaient catholiques
dans le catholicisme le libre arbitre de
l'homme est une donnée fondamentale
contrairement par exemple au
protestantisme
dans lequel le libre arbitre est nié
voilà pourquoi on ne peut pas se
contenter de dire la position chrétienne
en matière de libre arbitre
parce que la position chrétienne ça ne
veut rien dire
tout dépend de si on parle du
catholicisme ou du protestantisme
dans le protestantisme il y a l'idée de
prédestination
l'homme n'est pas libre il est
prédestiné
prédestiné par Dieu bien sûr
ça veut dire que dans une vision
protestante c'est Dieu qui décide
pas l'homme
c'est Dieu qui décide par exemple si
vous aurez la foi ou non
c'est Dieu qui décide si vous ferez le
bien ou le mal
si vous serez heureux ou malheureux
alors il y a un passage de la Bible qui
justifie en quelque sorte l'idée de
prédestination
ça se trouve dans l'épître aux Éphésiens
il s'agit d'une lettre adressée par
l'apôtre Paul à l'église des fesses et
qui dit je cite en lui nous sommes aussi
devenus
héritiers ayant été prédestiné suivant
la résolution de celui qui opère toute
chose d'après le conseil de sa volonté
donc on voit ici que le terme de
prédestination apparaît explicitement
et donc pendant plusieurs siècles il va
y avoir une vie polémique au sein du
christianisme pour savoir si les hommes
sont effectivement prédestinés ou s'ils
sont libres
et pourquoi c'est important
c'est important parce que si les hommes
sont prêts destinés
ça signifie qu'il ne sert à rien de
travailler au salut de son âme
ça ne sert à rien de se réformer ça ne
sert à rien de chercher à attendre vers
le bien
étant donné que c'est Dieu qui décide
qui œuvre pour le bien et qui œuvre pour
le mal
donc si les hommes sont prédestinés ça
revient à dire que l'Église ne sert à
rien
et donc c'est ce qui fait que l'Église
catholique va finalement jeter la natale
sur cette idée de prédestination
et qu'elle va condamner tous les
religieux chrétiens qui soutiennent
cette idée
et au XVIème siècle on aboutira à la
fameuse Réforme de Luther qui va donner
lieu à la scission entre les catholiques
qui croient dans le libre arbitre et les
protestants qui croient en la
prédestination
donc à l'époque où vit Descartes la
scission entre catholiques et
protestants a déjà eu lieu
et Descartes est profondément attachées
à la doctrine catholique
et dans le catholicisme on considère que
l'homme possède le libre arbitre et que
c'est d'ailleurs ça le sens de la phrase
Dieu a créé l'homme à son image
Dieu a créé l'homme à son image ça ne
veut pas dire que Dieu possède de bras
de jambes et une tête
ça veut dire que l'homme a reçu de Dieu
l'un de ses attributs essentiels à
savoir la liberté
la liberté c'est l'attribut divin par
excellence
parce que Dieu n'est déterminé par rien
d'autre que par lui-même
il n'est déterminé que par sa propre
volonté
et à un niveau humain la liberté ça
consiste à pouvoir
discerner le bien et le mal
et donc à pouvoir choisir entre le bien
et le mal
ce qui veut dire que dans une vision
catholique les hommes sont responsables
du mal qu'ils font
si les hommes font le mal c'est qu'ils
l'ont décidé
en vertu de leur pouvoir de discernement
c'est donc pas Dieu qui est responsable
du mal
ce n'est pas à Dieu qu'il faut imputer
le mal
il faut l'imputer aux hommes
quand on veut réfuter la croyance en
Dieu je parle ici du Dieu des religions
du dieu définit comme être créateur du
monde et de l'humanité
il y a un argument qui revient souvent
qui consiste à dire oui mais votre Dieu
là
il laisse faire le mal
à vous nous dites que Dieu est bon
qu'il est
omni bénévolant
donc comment se fait-il que Dieu
autorise le mal s'il est supposé être
bon
pourquoi John intervient-il pas pour
empêcher le mal
puisqu'il en a le pouvoir
donc de choses l'une ou bien Dieu
n'existe pas
ou bien Dieu existe mais il est mauvais
puisqu'il laisse les hommes commettre le
mal
la réponse à cet argument c'est de dire
que la bonté de Dieu
s'exprime justement dans le fait que
nous soyons libres
le don de la liberté c'est ça la marque
de la générosité divine
parce que la liberté est la plus haute
distinction qui soit
une distinction divine
Dieu est bon parce qu'il nous a doté de
son attribut suprême
l'attribut qui donne à nos actes une
valeur et un sens
quelle valeur aurait nos actes si nous
étions programmés à faire le bien
quel enseignement retirait ton des
choses
quelle élévation pourrait-on espérer
si tout était joué d'avance
Dieu n'est pas mauvais parce qu'il
laisse le mal exister
Dieu est bon parce qu'il nous a donné la
possibilité de connaître le bien et de
le préférer au mal
c'est ça l'idée
Dieu n'aurait pas été bon si il avait
fait de nous des automates moraux
car dans ce cas-là une pièce aux échecs
aurait plus de dignité que l'être humain
la dignité de l'homme réside dans sa
liberté
dans sa capacité à choisir et à se
rectifier
je rappelle que étymologiquement
rectifier signifie redresser
et se redresser c'est à la fois se
rendre droit et s'élever
la liberté nous élève
donc dans cette perspective Dieu est bon
parce qu'il nous laisse le choix
et si Dieu nous laisse le choix ça veut
dire que le mal ne vient pas de lui mais
de nous
ça veut dire que nous sommes
responsables du mal sur terre
Dieu n'est pas responsable du mal il est
responsable de la possibilité du mal
et oui mais c'est pas pareil
quand on fait un choix le responsable de
notre choix c'est nous pas celui qui
nous offre le choix
quand une possibilité inclut le bien et
le mal le mal ne se situe pas dans la
possibilité mais dans le choix du mal
donc quand des gens disent il fait quoi
votre Dieu quand des innocents sont tués
il fait quoi votre Dieu quand des
enfants souffrent
exactement ce qu'a fait Voltaire
Voltaire a écrit un poème qui s'appelle
le désastre de Lisbonne
dans lequel il se moque de cette
croyance
quel crime quelle faute ont commis ses
enfants sur le sein maternel écrasé et
sanglant
Voltaire ne supporte pas cette idée que
Dieu pourrait autoriser le mal
donc à la question que fait votre Dieu
quand des innocents subissent le mal la
réponse est il ne fait rien
il ne fait rien parce que c'est pas son
rôle
pas parce qu'il est méchant
pas parce qu'il n'en est pas capable
mais justement par choix
c'est la volonté de Dieu que les hommes
soient libres de commettre le mal pour
le comprendre
le comète pour le connaître
le connaître pour ne plus le commettre
faire le bien par ignorance du mal ce
n'est pas faire le bien
parce qu'on a pas de mérite à ne pas
faire quelque chose qu'on ne connaît pas
on est conscient de ce qu'est le bien
que lorsqu'on est conscient de ce qu'est
le mal
et c'est alors qu'on devient libre de
faire le bien
faire le bien par programmation faire le
bien par prédestination
ce n'est pas faire le bien
parce que c'est faire quelque chose sans
le comprendre
comme une récitation
Dieu ne veut pas que nous récitions le
bien
il veut que nous l'assimilions
on rejoint ainsi l'idée de Kant
lorsqu'il disait que faire le bien par
obligation faire le bien par contrainte
ce n'était pas faire le bien puisque ça
ne vient pas de nous
si je m'empêche de faire du mal à mon
voisin parce que j'ai peur des
représailles ou parce que j'ai peur
qu'il porte plainte
je ne suis pas dans le bien
je suis dans l'imitation du bien
parce qu'alors je ne fais pas le bien
par volonté mais par un motif extérieur
ou bien
le seul bien véritable c'est le bien
volontaire
c'est à dire libre
et bien de la même façon si le bien a
une valeur c'est précisément parce qu'il
ne nous est pas imposé mais proposer
c'est précisément parce que nous pouvons
faire le choix de lui désobéir
nous sommes libres quand nous pouvons
désobéir
alors bien sûr si vous êtes athée si
vous êtes matérialiste
et que toutes ces histoires de religion
ça vous rendent par une oreille et ça
ressort par l'autre
l'argument théologique
l'idée que nous sommes libres parce que
Dieu lui-même est libre et qui nous a
créé à son image
cet argument là ben il y a peu de
chances pour que vous le trouviez
convaincant
donc on va aller voir un peu les autres
arguments que nous propose des cartes en
espérant que certains d'entre eux seront
un peu plus probants
c'est dans ces principes de philosophie
publiés en 1644 que Descartes exposent
sa vision de la liberté humaine
il expose sa vision de la liberté et il
écrit je cite
il est si évident que nous avons une
volonté libre qui peut donner son
consentement ou ne pas le donner quand
bon lui semble que cela peut être compté
pour une de nos plus communes notions
la liberté de notre volonté se connaît
sans preuve par la seule expérience que
nous en avons fin de citation
donc voilà le passage le plus souvent
cité en référence quand on parle de la
liberté chez Descartes
sauf que
il y a un problème
il y a un problème parce que si on
résume ce que nous dit des cartes
il nous dit la liberté existe parce
qu'on en fait tous l'expérience
on fait tous l'expérience de notre
liberté autrement dit on sait qu'on est
libre parce qu'on se sent libre
et bien il est là le problème
parce que ça c'est pas un argument
c'est pas un argument tout simplement
parce que ce sentir libre ça ne veut pas
dire être libre
autrement dit un sentiment n'est pas une
preuve
et ce qui est encore plus gênant c'est
que en parallèle
Descartes est le premier à dire que ce
n'est pas parce qu'on croit faire
l'expérience de quelque chose que cette
chose est réelle
pourquoi Descartes est-il le plus connu
il est connu pour son cogito
je pense donc je suis
quelle est l'origine du cogito c'est
l'idée que nos sens sont trompeurs
que nos sens ne sont pas fiables
on a des perceptions et que ces
perceptions ne sont pas forcément le
reflet de la réalité
et que donc la raison doit venir
corriger les données de la perception
voilà un philosophe qui nous dit qu'il
faut se méfier de nos perceptions il
faut se méfier de l'expérience
et qu'il a tout à coup nous dit que la
liberté existe parce qu'on en fait
l'expérience
ça va pas
c'est pas suffisant
et c'est d'autant moins suffisant que 30
ans après la publication de ses
principes de philosophie
paraissait l'Éthique de Spinoza
et l'un des points majeurs de la pensée
de Spinoza
c'est précisément de dire que l'homme
s'illusionne lorsqu'il se croit libre
parce qu'il confond liberté et sentiment
de liberté
la liberté nous dit spinosa ce n'est pas
un sentiment
à fortiori qu'on se sentiment et le
produit de notre ignorance
on disait tout à l'heure pour Spinoza la
liberté est une illusion
une illusion qui provient de l'ignorance
des causes qui nous déterminent
on se croit libre quand on ne connaît
pas tous les éléments qui ont conduit à
notre choix
quand on ignore l'historique les causes
et des effets qui ont concouru à notre
prise de décision
c'est ça le déterminisme
l'idée qu'il n'y a pas d'effet sans
cause et que tout action est l'effet
nécessaire de cause qu'il appréciente
Descartes n'est pas d'accord avec ça
il n'est pas d'accord au sens où il
considère qu'il y a une cause sur
déterminante à nos actions
une cause proprement humaine une cause
qu'on ne peut pas mettre au même niveau
que les autres
et cette cause
c'est le jugement
l'être humain est libre parce que
contrairement aux choses de la nature
qui sont déterminées
l'être humain est capable de jugement
alors
expliquons un peu ça
si on admet avec Spinoza que tout est
déterminé
aussi bien les choses de la nature que
nos actions ou que nos pensées
il y a malgré tout une différence entre
le déterminisme des choses et le
déterminisme humain
pourquoi
parce que les choses se comportent de
manière purement mécanique
pour le dire simplement un corps ne
pense pas
si vous lâchez un corps
il va tomber
automatiquement
inéluctablement
donc il y a un déterminisme physique qui
semble difficile à contester
en revanche s'agissant de l'homme
ces actions sont influencées par ces
jugements
l'être humain n'est pas simplement un
être physique il n'est pas seulement un
être de matière
il est aussi un être pensant
un être capable de former des jugements
et pour Descartes c'est le jugement qui
détermine nos actes
on va tenter d'illustrer ça par la
distinction que fait des cartes entre le
comportement humain et le comportement
animal
les cartes nous dit la différence entre
l'homme et l'animal c'est que les hommes
agissent par jugement
tandis que les animaux agissent par
instinct
pour être encore plus précis les cartes
nous dit les animaux agissent par la
disposition de leurs organes
ce qui revient en faire des êtres
purement mécaniques
autrement dit pour Descartes les animaux
n'ont pas de volonté
ils n'ont pas de volonté parce qu'ils ne
forment pas de jugement
parce qu'ils n'ont pas l'aptitude à la
délibération intérieure
or pour qu'il y ait volonté il faut
qu'il y ait une délibération intérieure
dont la volonté soit le résultat
il faut qu'il y ait conscience des
motivations de notre volonté
or les animaux n'ont pas conscience de
leur motivation
c'est le propre de l'instant
le fait d'agir sans réfléchir le fait
d'agir sans se poser la question de
pourquoi on agit ainsi
quand les hirondelles migral automne et
qu'elle revienne au printemps elle ne le
font pas parce qu'elles ont réfléchi
elles le font parce que leur instinct
les épousses
l'instinct est par définition
irraisonnée il réfléchit
bien ça c'est la grande différence nous
dit Descartes entre l'homme et l'animal
à savoir que l'homme n'agit pas par
instinct mais par jugement
quand on parle de jugement on parle en
réalité de deux types de jugement
le jugement intellectuel et le jugement
moral
le jugement moral c'est la distinction
entre le bien et le mal
le jugement intellectuel c'est la
distinction entre le vrai et le faux
on va commencer par le jugement moral
chez les animaux il n'y a pas de moral
il n'y a ni bien ni mal
il y a ce que prescrivent les lois de la
nature
c'est pour ça qu'on dira jamais qu'à un
fauve se comporte mal quand il dévore sa
proie
il se contente d'exécuter son code
génétique
à l'inverse l'homme est un être moral
un être capable de discerner le bien et
le mal
ce qui fait que l'homme à la possibilité
on y revient il a la possibilité de
choisir le bien ou de choisir le mal
alors bien sûr dans les faits les choses
sont rarement aussi binaires
il est rare qu'on se dise je choisis de
faire le mal et j'en suis très fier
mais le fait est qu'on a tous déjà fait
l'expérience du choix moral
du dilemme moral
c'est-à-dire de la possibilité d'agir
dans un sens plutôt que dans un autre
et bien pour Descartes c'est ça la
liberté
la liberté c'est la possibilité que nous
avons à chaque instant
d'agir non pas par instinct mais par
jugement moral
c'est la possibilité que nous avons de
délibérer intérieurement avant d'agir
c'est la conscience morale
alors oui on peut théoriser sur la
conscience morale
en disant qu'elle n'est que le produit
de notre évolution biologique
ou qu'elle n'est qu'une construction
culturelle peu importe
ce qui compte c'est le fait que la
morale existe pour nous
et dès lors qu'elle existe pour nous
elle a un impact sur nos actions
à partir du moment où vous avez une
conscience morale vous êtes libre
parce qu'avoir une conscience morale
c'est savoir qu'à tout moment vous
pouvez choisir le bien comme vous pouvez
choisir le mal
si vous choisissez le mal vous
choisissez le mal
si vous choisissez le bien vous
choisissez le bien
c'est vous qui décidez
parce que c'est vous qui agissez
alors si vous avez bien écouté ce qu'on
a dit tout à l'heure à propos de Spinoza
vous aurez compris que Spinoza ne
partage pas du tout cet avis
Spinoza ne pense pas que lorsque nous
agissons ce soit le résultat d'une
délibération intérieure
pour le dire autrement il ne pense pas
que ce soit nos jugements qui
déterminent nos actes
plutôt que ce sont nos actes qui
déterminent nos jugements
on rappellera sa célèbre phrase qui dit
nous ne désirons pas une chose parce que
nous la jugons bonne nous la jugeons
bonne parce que nous la désirons
si on applique cette citation au domaine
de la morale ça signifie que nous
n'effectuons pas une action parce que
nous la jugeons moralement bonne
nous la jugeons moralement bonne parce
que nous effectuons
pour Spinoza ce ne sont pas des
considérations morales qui nous poussent
à agir
les considérations morales viennent
après notre action
pour la justifier
ce qui nous pousse à agir selon Spinoza
ce sont des forces beaucoup plus
difficiles à identifier
ce qu'il appelle des affects
alors admettons
admettons l'objection de Spinoza
admettons que lorsqu'on agit ce ne sont
pas des paramètres moraux qui nous
motivent mais des paramètres affectifs
ça n'enlève rien au fait que placé face
à un choix l'homme peut agir d'une
certaine manière comme il peut agir
d'une autre manière
en d'autres termes quel que soit les
causes réelles et profondes de nos choix
le choix est toujours possible
et la délibération morale demeure
on va prendre un exemple
imaginez que vous avez un couple d'amis
avec qui vous partez en vacances ou avec
qui vous passez le réveillon du nouvel
an
et un beau jour au détour d'une rue
vous surprenez l'un de ces deux amis en
train d'embrasser une autre personne
vous surprenez cette amie en flagrant
délit d'adultère
et là vous vous dites qu'est-ce que je
dois faire
est-ce que je dois le dire à l'ami
trompé
est-ce que je dois en parler à l'ami que
j'ai pris en flagrant délit
est-ce que je dois me taire
parce qu'après tout c'est pas mes
affaires
c'est délicat
donc vous êtes dans une situation dans
laquelle vous avez trois options
et vous devez choisir entre l'une de ces
trois options
étant entendu que le nom choix est un
choix
ne rien dire c'est choisir de ne rien
dire
et bien la question n'est pas tant de
savoir ce que vous allez faire
la question est de savoir
qu'est-ce qui va se passer dans votre
conscience
parce qu'il va s'en passer des choses
dans votre conscience
vous allez vous interroger
vous allez passer moi l'expression vous
prendre la tête
et à l'issue de cette prise de tête quel
que soit votre décision vous aurez fait
l'expérience de la prise de décision
l'expérience du choix
et que votre choix soit déterminé par
votre pur volonté ou qu'il soit
déterminé par tout un tas de facteurs
extérieurs
dans tous les cas vous devez faire un
choix
et bien c'est dans ce choix que vous
faites l'expérience de la liberté
et un spinosia peut bien venir vous dire
que votre choix est déterminé vous vous
en foutez
parce que vous tout ce que vous voyez
c'est que vous avez une décision à
prendre
et que personne ne la prendra à votre
place
même pas le déterminisme
le déterminisme viendra après coup pour
expliquer votre décision
mais le déterminisme ne prend pas la
décision à votre place
c'est vous qui prenez la décision
personne d'autre
c'est ça la liberté
la conscience qu'il existe plusieurs
options possibles face à une situation
et qu'avant que vous n'ayez pris votre
décision votre choix est imprévisible
la liberté c'est quand on ne sait pas ce
que vous allez faire
quand vous même vous ne savez pas ce que
vous allez faire
quand personne ne sait ce que vous allez
faire
par conséquent le déterminisme ne
s'oppose pas à la liberté
le déterminisme inclut la liberté
il inclut toutes les possibilités qui se
présentent à vous comme autant
d'éléments que votre conscience morale
va devoir tenter de démêler
et aussi paradoxal que ça puisse être
c'est ça qui fait de vous un être libre
l'homme est capable d'hésiter
il est capable de se retenir
de résister
de se repentir
pour des raisons morales
l'animal ne connaît pas le repentir
parce qu'il vient en accord avec son
instinct
il se confond avec son instinct
donc il ne sait pas ce que c'est lui
d'avoir un conflit moral
la différence entre l'homme et l'animal
ce n'est pas que l'homme n'est pas
influencé
c'est que même lorsqu'il est influencé
l'homme peut agir à l'encontre de ce
qu'il influence
être libre c'est pouvoir agir autrement
on en revient au péché d'Adam et Eve
Adam et Eve avait été prévenu qu'il ne
devait pas goûter le fruit défendu
et l'on fait quand même
ils ont agi autrement que ce que
prévoyait la règle
ils ont donc été puni
puni parce que prévu
puni parce que dès lors qu'ils ont été
prévenus ils deviennent responsables de
leur acte
la liberté implique la responsabilité
et réciproquement
mais l'homme ne possède pas seulement
une conscience morale
l'homme possède aussi une raison
et c'est également parce qu'il possède
une raison que l'homme est libre
la raison c'est ce qui permet à l'homme
d'évaluer une situation
de l'analyser de comparer
de déduire
lorsque nous sommes confrontés à une
situation
nous pouvons prendre du recul
une distance critique
une distance qui va nous permettre de
mieux comprendre la situation
pour y réagir de manière adéquate
la liberté réside dans cette faculté
ce qui rejoint d'ailleurs l'idée de
Spinoza selon laquelle plus on comprend
plus on est libre
la raison c'est ce qui fait qu'on ne va
pas se jeter dans l'action la tête la
première
c'est ce qui va nous permettre de nous
adapter à la situation
de nous y adapter beaucoup plus que ne
pourrait le faire un animal
car l'animal n'est pas en mesure
d'identifier les médiations entre les
choses
ou un niveau extrêmement faible
si nous ne possédions pas la raison nous
serions comme des mouches
à nous cogner indéfiniment la tête
contre le carreau de la fenêtre
alors que la fenêtre est ouverte
prendre du recul
[Musique]
l'homme n'agit pas comme mouche
en tout cas il a la faculté de ne pas
agir comme une mouche
sa liberté réside dans le fait d'exercer
sa pensée
dans le fait que son action peut être le
résultat d'un raisonnement et non pas
seulement d'une impulsion
elle est là la différence
un enfant n'est pas libre au sens où ces
facultés de raisonnement ne lui
permettent pas d'avoir pleinement
conscience des médiations entre les
choses
son jugement n'est pas éclairé
par exemple si vous allez retirer de
l'argent au distributeur
et que votre enfant de 5 ans vous
accompagne
il est probable qu'il vous dise mais
pourquoi tu en prends pas plus
parce que pour lui il n'y a pas de
médiation il n'y a pas de lien causal
entre le fait de retirer de l'argent au
distributeur et le fait que cet argent
soit prélevé sur votre compte
raison pour laquelle on dit que les
enfants sont sans filtre
ils n'ont pas de filtre parce qu'ils
n'ont pas accès à la série des
médiations entre les choses
et c'est pour cette raison là qu'ils ne
sont pas autonomes
et que le fonctionnement du monde reste
pour eux dans une large mesure
incompréhensible
et cette absence d'autonomie débouche
sur une absence de responsabilité
on ne va pas punir son enfant parce
qu'il n'a pas compris le fonctionnement
d'un distributeur de billets
on va lui expliquer
on va lui expliquer les médias sont
jusqu'à ce qu'il les comprennent
et quand ils les ont comprises il sera
autonome
ces jugements seront éclairés
et c'est seulement à ce moment là
lorsqu'il aura atteint l'âge de raison
que l'enfant deviendra un être libre
la liberté c'est la clairvoyance du
jugement
et quand les capacités de jugement sont
altérés
comme par exemple chez les personnes
atteintes d'une déficience mentale
ou chez les personnes sous emprise
mentale
c'est la liberté elle-même qui est
altérée
le conditionnement mental ça consiste à
entraver chez la personne le processus
de discernement
la personne croit être libre elle croit
former un jugement lucide
précisément parce qu'elle est
inconsciente de ce qu'elle ignore
elle confond son champ de connaissance
avec le champ de la connaissance
elle prend son ignorance pour un savoir
c'est pour ça qu'on disait tout à
l'heure que le sentiment de liberté
n'était pas la preuve de l'existence de
la liberté
sinon ça reviendrait à dire qu'une
personne manipulée est libre puisqu'elle
se croit libre
et c'est là qu'on en revient à Spinoza
Spinoza qui contrairement à une idée
répandue ne disait pas que la liberté
était impossible
mais qu'elle était difficile
et quelle résidait dans notre niveau de
connaissance des choses
de connaissance
des causes
plus on connaît plus on est libre
plus on ignore
plus on est esclave
Spinoza n'était pas le seul à dire que
la raison nous rend libre
les premiers à avoir développé cette
idée ce sont les stoïciens
les stock des cartes à étudier en
profondeur durant sa jeunesse
au point qu'on pourra trouver dans
certains textes de Descartes des
citations qu'on croirait emprunter à
Sénèque ou à Marc Aurèle
dans son Discours de la méthode
Descartes écrits par exemple
ma troisième Maxime était de tâcher
toujours plus tôt à me vaincre que la
fortune et à changer mes désirs plutôt
que l'ordre du monde
et il ajoute il n'y a rien qui soit
entièrement en notre pouvoir que nos
pensées en sorte qu'après que nous avons
fait notre mieux touchant les choses qui
nous sont extérieures tous ceux qui
manque de nous réussir et au regard de
nous absolument impossible et ceci seul
me semblait être suffisant pour
m’empêcher de rien désirer à l'avenir
que je naquisse et ainsi pour me rendre
compte
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre
la liberté c'est la conformité à la
raison
vouloir l'impossible ou vouloir ce qui
ne dépend pas de nous
ce n'est pas être libre
c'est au contraire être l'esclave d'une
illusion
on confond souvent la liberté et
l'indétermination
l'indétermination c'est le pouvoir que
nous aurions plutôt que nous voudrions
avoir
de ne pas être soumis à l'ordre des
choses
l'indétermination c'est le désir de
s'extraire de toutes les contraintes
aussi bien extérieurs qu'intérieur
aussi bien physique que mentale
et donc on dira nous ne sommes pas
libres parce que tout ce que nous
faisons est le résultat d'un
enchaînement de causes et des faits
mais évidemment
la liberté ce n'est pas la mort de la
causalité
ce n'est pas sortir de la causalité
parce que dans ce cas là ça reviendrait
à identifier la liberté à l'impossible
la liberté ce n'est pas l'impossible
ce n'est pas l'absence de cause
la liberté ce n'est pas dire de plus 2 =
où est la liberté là-dedans
ça c'est une conception fantaisiste de
la liberté
une conception fantaisiste qui voudrait
nous faire croire que pour être libre il
faudrait pouvoir affirmer tout et son
contraire
qu'il faudrait pouvoir être tout et son
mais ça ce n'est pas de la liberté
c'est d'imagination
la liberté n'est pas une affaire
d'imagination
la liberté est une affaire de raison
je cite
il n'y a que la seule volonté que
j'expérimente en moi être si grande que
je ne conçois point l'idée d'aucune
autre plus ample et plus étendue en
sorte que c'est elle principalement qui
me fait connaître que je porte l'image
et la ressemblance de Dieu car encore
qu'elle soit incomparablement plus
grande dans Dieu que dans moi soit
raison de la connaissance et de la
puissance qui s'y trouve en jointes la
rente plus ferme et plus efficace soit à
raison de l'objet d'autant qu'elle se
porte et s'étend infiniment à plus de
choses elle ne me semble pas toutefois
plus grande si je la considère
formellement et précisément en elle-même
car elle consiste seulement en ce que
nous pouvons faire une chose ou ne la
faire pas c'est à dire affirmer ou nier
poursuivre ou fuir ou plutôt seulement
en ce que pour affirmer ou nier pour
suivre ou fuir les choses que
l'entendement nous propose nous agissons
en tel sorte que nous ne sentons point
qu'aucune force extérieure nous y
contraigne car afin que je sois libre il
n'est pas nécessaire que je sois
indifférent à choisir l'un ou l'autre
des deux contraires mais plutôt d'autant
plus que je penche vers l'un soit que je
connaisse évidemment que le bien et le
vrai s'y rencontre soit que Dieu dispose
ainsi l'intérieur de ma pensée d'autant
plus librement j'en fais choix et je
l'embrasse et certes la grâce divine et
la connaissance naturelle bien loin de
diminuer ma liberté l'augmente plutôt et
la fortification de façon que cet
indifférence que je sens lorsque je ne
suis point emporté vers un côté plutôt
que vers un autre par le poids d'aucune
raison et le plus bas de gré de la
liberté et fait plutôt paraître un
défaut dans la connaissance qu'une
perfection dans la volonté car si je
connaissais toujours clairement ce qui
est vrai et ce qui est bon je ne serai
jamais en peine de délibérer quel
jugement et qu'elle soit je devrais
faire et aussi je serai entièrement
libre sans jamais être indifférent
nous cherchons tous à être libre
à nous affranchir des contraintes
des dépendances
des nécessités
et dans le même temps nous agissons
comme si nous tenions à ces dépendances
comme si nous avions peur de nous en
libérer
la question n'est pas de savoir si la
liberté existe ou si elle est une
illusion
la question est de savoir
que sommes-nous prêts à faire
pour gagner notre liberté
sommes-nous prêts à perdre ce que nous
avons
notre situation
notre réputation
reproche
sommes-nous prêts à nous émanciper du
regard des autres
et à croire en nous et en ce que nous
voulons
au fond parler de liberté
ne serait-ce pas le moyen que nous avons
trouvé
de ne pas exercer notre liberté
d'oublier qu'au-delà de tous les
déterminismes
à chaque fois qu'un choix se présente à
nous
à chaque fois que nous sommes sur le
point de faire un choix
nous sommes condamnés à être libre
je vous remercie
[Musique]